[Music]
the emperor of a city in china has been
longing for a daughter after having 15
sons over the course of 15 years his
wife goes into labor and gives birth to
the long-awaited princess everyone in
the palace is over the moon until the
head nurse passes out it turns out that
the new princess has a disgustingly
pungent body odor that can knock people
unconscious the king is informed about a
fainting epidemic where 15 nannies five
nurses and two guards have passed out
because they could smell the newborn the
head doctor of the palace reveals that
the princess suffers from severe
atypical reeking syndrome causing
excessive emission of body odor
unfortunately a cure to this problem
hasn't been developed yet but the doctor
is confident he will cure the princess
in a few days until then they have to
wear masks to take care of her a week
goes by but with no progress in finding
the cure sometimes her smell passes
through the mask and makes everyone
nauseous for the welfare of the entire
palace the king orders the princess to
be taken to the riverside residence away
from everyone else time passes and the
princess grows up to become a beautiful
young girl but her body odor remains the
same she has tried different kinds of
baths medicines and soaps but nothing
helps at this point in her life she has
accepted her fate as the stinking queen
but is worried that she will remain
unmarried because of the disease her
parents are equally worried for her and
are constantly looking for a suitable
man who will accept her despite her
smell one day they arrange a matchmaking
ceremony where a bunch of men will be
invited for the princess to choose from
the maids bathe her in flowers and
fragrance even though they do nothing to
help with the odor to suppress the smell
she is made to wear clothes that cover
her entire body but when in front of the
candidates the princess sneezes making
everyone able to smell her some men
vomit others faint and the surviving
ones run away by jumping into the pond
when the king stops a guy he stabs
himself because he would rather dive and
have a smelly wife the event shakes the
princess's confidence and she starts
hating herself as much as others hate
her smell after that we are introduced
to a florist named kai he is best known
for creating fragrant flowery perfumes
for the ladies of the town kai's biggest
wish in life is to be the ambassador of
aromatherapy and cure diseases using his
skills one afternoon he sees a poster
issued by the palace saying that anyone
who cures the princess's disease will
get to marry her and become the royal
consort kai doesn't really care about
marrying the princess but he is eager to
prove that aromatherapy works and he
believes that his flowers can cure her
we see that he has a plethora of flowers
growing at his house including a smelly
one called stinky weed which sounds
awesome but smells really bad
even though most people would find the
plant repulsive kai loves it as much as
the rest then comes the day of the
competition where six selected
candidates have to make three smelly
objects odor free they get to work
immediately some using magic others
using chemicals while kai uses his
homemade fragrance i want to know what
those magicians are doing after a rough
battle only kai and a young doctor named
yay are able to complete the task they
are given three months to create a
formula or a technique that will cure
the princess if kai is successful the
palace doctor will be humiliated so he
wants his junior yea to win he tries his
best to discredit kai's abilities
because he was born to a lower class
family however the king allows him to
participate disregarding the royal
doctor's suggestion for the next few
days kai works hard to create the most
fragrant soap he has ever made to look
for subjects he can test it on he goes
to the fish market to his surprise a
woman falls on him while trying to lift
a heavy fish she is none other than the
princess who has disguised herself as a
fisherwoman named hyung she blames her
smell on the fish so people won't think
she is weird upon finding out that he is
here looking for smelly people the
princess convinces her fisherman friends
to help him they come to his house where
they are made to shower for about an
hour using the soap on every corner of
their bodies kai smells them afterward
and passes out because the soap didn't
work at all after the fisherman leave
hyung offers to be his test subject for
free an excited kai performs steam
therapy green water therapy mummy wrap
bath and other techniques on her but
nothing works to cure the gut-wrenching
smell of her body meanwhile kai's
competitor yay is working with the royal
doctor he wants to make sure that kai
doesn't win because it will ruin the
reputation of the entire royal medical
association they are willing to go to
any lengths to prevent kai from
developing the cure the next day kai and
young continue the experiments kai
notices that the smell of his stinky
weed powder has vanished for some reason
he dismisses it as a mistake and
continues working on other powders when
it is time for hyung to leave it starts
to rain heavily she stays with him for
the night and kai is shocked to see that
hyung sleeps with her smelly clothes and
shoes on in reality the clothes confide
her smell to some extent which is why
she never takes them off the following
morning they go to the forest to pick
some wildflowers it starts raining again
and they have to take shelter under
kai's jacket being this close to hyung
he can smell the awful scent on her and
expresses his disgust she had started to
like him more than a friend hence the
comment breaks her heart a confused kai
watches as she runs away in anger some
time later kai returns home to see all
his flowers have been destroyed except
the stinky weed seeking comfort he picks
the stinky weed i mean he goes to meet
hyung and finds her dancing alone still
angry she hits him with stones refusing
to believe that his house was trashed
kai drinks for the rest of the night and
falls down in the middle of the street
this is when he sees women sweating and
comes up with an idea he wants to create
medicine from women's sweat since it
might suppress the odor with its own
smell that way one can just take a
shower and remove the sweat medicine and
their body would be odorless kai asks
for help from the fisherman and they
agree after hyung convinces them for the
next hour they make a group of women
dance continuously and collect their
sweat then kai works the entire night
and creates the magical potion but just
when it is ready a masked burglar
attacks him and breaks the vial kai
chases the man and ends up in yay's
house the doctor claims that he never
went out of the house and since kai
doesn't have any proof he can do nothing
there is an entire group of scientists
working with yay which shakes kai's
spirit especially now that his work is
ruined in the following scene he is
alone in his home when hyung arrives
with a bucket full of sweat so he can
continue the experiment the gesture
touches kai's heart and he asks her to
stay the night hyung sings him a
beautiful song that calms his nerves and
helps him focus a few days later kai
completes the formula and sprays it on
the fishermen to see if it works he
wants to test it on hyung as well but
she pretends to be allergic to sweat so
her true identity isn't revealed the
potion works perfectly on men and makes
them smell better even though it is not
a permanent solution kai is happy to
have made some progress still they have
to use it on a woman to see if it'll
work on the princess too at night the
group goes into the palace to meet the
only smelly woman in the town other than
the princess she is the royal doctor's
wife known for her smelly farts the
group hides outside the toilet and uses
the formula on her only to discover the
solution doesn't work on women or maybe
it just doesn't work on farts for the
next few days kai works day and night
disregarding his health hyung finds him
bleeding out his nose because he is
sniffing too many times she forces him
to take a rest for the night even though
kai is not a fan of the idea the next
morning he goes to the woods and comes
across an old couple burying flowers in
the ground they reveal that they like to
give dead flowers a proper burial the
couple turns out to be botanists with
vast knowledge about different kinds of
vegetation when asked what are the most
fragrant flowers of all time they name
four flowers that grow in four different
seasons the couple leaves shortly after
but this gives kai a brilliant idea that
will definitely work as a cure he tells
hyung that he has to travel around china
to collect four seasonal flowers she
offers to join him and the two set off
for a month-long journey to places with
different climates they bond while
traveling and return home after a
successful trip by now they only have a
week before the three-month experiment
period ends kai gets sick so hyung uses
his diary to make the formula for him
since kai's nose is stuffy he cannot
smell her and they end up sharing a bed
at night eventually judgment day comes
and hyung allows him to cure the
princess and marry her kai doesn't feel
comfortable leaving her behind but he
has to prove that the aromatherapy works
in the following scene the competitors
are in front of the king and the
princess is behind a tent yay goes first
and uses several pressure points to try
to make her odorless however it disrupts
her sense of smell and only she cannot
smell her odor he promises to perform
the same procedure on every citizen so
they won't smell her scent and she can
be free the king remains unimpressed and
asks kai to continue the royal doctor
tries to intervene but kai proves that
he has no sense of smell at all which is
why he is incompetent to make a judgment
the king kicks the doctor out of the
palace for lying to him and pretending
to be working on a cure following that
the princess is made to eat the tablet
which actually cures the disease and
makes her smell great everything goes
well until she comes out of the tent
revealing that the medicine only worked
for some time the king is about to
execute kai but stops upon hearing the
princess crying when her tear drops to
the ground kai has an epiphany he begs
the king to give him one more day so he
can add something to the medicine i
wonder if it's farts kai is granted 24
hours hence he goes to meet hyung
immediately he recalls the time that the
powdered stinky weed lost its scent
because her tears had landed on it the
previous day he thinks if her tears are
added to the medicine it will surely
work to make kion cry kai tells her that
he knows the smell isn't coming from her
clothes but from her body hyung reveals
that she never had friends when she was
little and even her family disgraces her
all because of this stupid disease one
day she jumped into the river to commit
the unthinkable and was saved by the
fishermen after coming back to life she
finally discovered that she is not a
diseased outsider when she is in the
fish market which is why she started
living with them by the time she gets
done telling the story she has collected
enough tears kai thanks her for her help
but feels bad about everything that she
has been through the next day he goes to
the palace to submit the final product
but sees the doctor and his wife
together the doctor has no sense of
smell but he doesn't want to be cured
because then he wouldn't be able to live
his life with his wife and her smelly
farts the love between them makes kai
realize that he needs hyung in his life
strange takeaway but okay hence he runs
to the market where she is attending the
flower festival he gives her the
medicine and promises to love her
forever even if it doesn't work she
flies into his arms and takes the
medicine still kai goes to the palace to
apologize to the king for not completing
the task he asks to apologize to the
princess too and goes to her quarters to
his surprise he finds an odorless hyung
and discovers that she is the princess
she finally has a loving husband and a
nice smelling body in the last scene the
two get married as the entire city
celebrates the moral of the story is if
you smell bad go cry about it
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching